je suis un ancien sportif de haut niveau
c'est vrai j'ai vécu
mais
aussi jusqu'aux s'il est issu d'une
lignée de ce qui est des sportifs
mon père adrien duvillard même prénom
même nom que moi et mon oncle henri
divers ont tous les deux étaient des
grands sportifs à l'époque mon père des
60 qui a tout gagné et mon oncle henri
70 il a lui aussi tout gagné pour ma
part je gagne une coupe du monde dans
l'île à lillehammer en norvège en 93
j'ai été quatre fois champion de france
de ski dans une période de skieurs
surtout en tant que descendeur on prend
des risques
et quand on prend des risques mais bon
on assume le fait qu'on peut se blesser
donc j'ai eu des blessures à répétition
en 94 et 95 et ses blessures m'ont coupé
delà de la compétition pendant pendant
deux ans ensuite pour la saison 96-97 je
reviens au haut niveau
je me sens bien techniquement
physiquement mentalement je suis
enregistré en pleine forme et j'attaque
la saison 97 avec plein de plein de
motivation
la saison commence bien sûr la deuxième
production monde va garder en italie je
termine 5e je suis vraiment revenu aux
niveaux et des bus ferry dans début
janvier on va wengen en suisse pour
faire une coupe du monde
wengen c'est une grande épreuve de coupe
du monde soit premier entraînement
officiel ce termine deuxième de
l'entraînement donc je suis vraiment ça
me confirme que je suis vraiment revenir
au haut niveau et le 17 janvier 97
j'attaque le deuxième entraînement
officiel
cet accident le 17 janvier 97 m'a plongé
plusieurs jours dans le coma
j'ai cassé cinq côtes de vertèbres
perforé le poumon et pendant un jour on
savait pas si je restais là aussi je
vais faire un petit tour là où
finalement il monde il n'y a plus trop
de place là où redescend donc après le
coma quelques plusieurs jours après le
coma à l'hôpital ya mon entraîneur qui
vient le vent et puis on discute et judy
écoute dans un nom il les jeux
olympiques à nagano au japon
et moi je veux à tout prix y aller alors
on a mis au point un système avec mon
entraîneur on a mis au point un système
de mini objectif à partir du 17 janvier
97 pour aller sur les jo de nagano ont
fait les 98 le premier objectif qu'elle
est mis en place et de faire un test
physique en juin 97
pourquoi parce que mon corps est un
outil de travail c'est nous du travail
n'avait pas suffisamment récupéré
s'était même pas la peine d'aller plus
loin
j'utilise mon corps donc on joue on fait
des tests aux qualités sont bons et
encore la progression à faire mais ça
avance
ensuite en juillet c'était de refaire du
ski juste fait mon métier ce qui est
sage du 7 mois vous n'avez pas ce qui
hélas était juste reprendre le plaisir à
skier mais ensuite le troisième objectif
qu'on est mis en place qui étaient 8 et
hyper important c'est d'être refait de
la descente en septembre 97
pourquoi parce que je savais que mon
corps allait tenir
ok on sait gérer une douleur et à son
comme dit terminator la douleur n'est
qu'une information
donc on sait gérer la douleur en tant
que sportif par contre je savais pas si
mon mental à les tenir
je serais passé fait de reprendre de la
vitesse tout d'un coup j'ai par un gros
panneau stop qui a essayé mais en me
disant un coût de maintenance arête en
travers c'est fini donc j'ai rejoint
l'équipe de france au chili et là je
fais un test grandeur nature et en
faisant ce test m'aperçois que j'ai pas
eu peur j'ai eu un peu d'appréhension
mais pas de peur bleue quand on lui dit
ok c'est bon on continue on s'est dit si
tu passes cet objectif-là
ensuite il ya un coût américain où là il
va falloir travailler la quantité de
travail alors que l'équipe de france
était déjà solide keitel et qualitatifs
moi j'étais encore en faire un train de
faire du quantitatif mais c'est pas
grave
j'étais sur ma progression pour les
divers jeux olympiques ensuite faut le
reprendre le bain la haute compétition
le bain la coupe du monde et surtout se
qualifier pour les olympiques
l'équipe de france et de 10 athlètes et
ce dix athlètes tels que quatre qui vont
jeu et c'est pas les 4 plus sympa qui
vont jouer quel plus beau et que de
gentils cd4 résultats donc il faut les
prendre sa qualification donc sur la
première coupe du monde mon objectif
n'est pas la qualification mais de
reprendre confiance en moi
donc première coupe du monde je reprends
confiance au mois du ok maintenant c'est
bon je vais chercher la qualif
il me reste cinq courses nous qualifier
donc rentrer en france en val d'isère je
tente ma qualification je me rate
ensuite on va en italie je me rate
nouveau pas ma qualification et je suis
ton va à bormio je n'ai pas ma
qualification et ensuite ces deux cours
sont qualifiés soit l'avant dernière
course je me qualifie toujours pas moi
je débute une course me qualifier keith
bull en autriche et là j'arrive la barre
en disant ok c'est maintenant ou jamais
et la soie dernières courses je finis
quatrième de la coupe du monde et fait
partie des quatre français qui peuvent à
lauzun épique donc juste après la
qualification acquise bull jeux
olympiques aux jeux olympiques je fais
20 secondes et je tombe 20 secondes de
course et jetons je fais nord technique
et je tombe mais ça c'est pas le plus
important
en fait après les jeux a au printemps
j'ai arrêté ma carrière
pas que je ne peux plus techniquement ni
physiquement je pouvais encore il n'y a
pas de preuve mais je sentais intérieur
manque ma carrière était finie
alors après a commencé notre section qui
a duré un an
un an pour comprendre pourquoi j'ai le
sentiment que ma carrière était finie
alors que je pouvais encore et le plus
loin je sentais que la même vie la vie
m'avait envoyé un message lors de mon
accident et fois que je comprenne ce
message que je comprenne
pourquoi je me trouvais face à un mur un
moment donné alors j'ai commencé à
réfléchir sur soi différentes procès ce
procès qui les met en place et je me
suis dit mais quand j'ai regardé ça je
dis mais mince j'ai fait une erreur je
me suis programmé sur le mauvaise
objectifs seront les hôpitaux m quand
j'étais là-bas je me suis dit mais en
fait j'avais dit je veux aller aux jeux
olympiques
j'avais pas dit je veux gagner ou une
médaille donc je me suis dis finalement
je m'étais fait une mauvaise
programmation dès le départ je n'ai pas
programmer le bon objectif mais ça me
convenait pas ça me connaît pas lire
autre chose donc je suis parti sur une
deuxième lecture ce schéma là et je me
suis dit pour avoir une deuxième mouture
je vais enlever ce qui fait le sportif
de haut niveau c'est à dire la notion de
performance et les goûts j'ai enlevé les
gaules aux performances de l'équation et
je regardais ça avec un autre filtre et
là je me suis dit finalement en tant
qu'être humain c'était le bon objectif
par rapport au point de départ c'était
suffisamment difficile suffisamment
challenging finalement c'était le bon
objectif par rapport aux points départ
mais ça me suffisait toujours pas il ya
encore un truc non parce que ça c'est
une démarche mentale celui cerveau
gauche c'est de la raison il ya autre
chose qui était au fond de moi et je
veux savoir ce que c'est alors je me
suis mis à chercher et j'y ai mis mon
nom sur internet je marque adrien de
villars et puis le paragraphe de google
est apparu vous savez c'est marqué 17
janvier trois petits points celle qui
paragraphe comme saveurs joue le
paragraphe en me disant tiens il parle
comme accident et quand j'ouvre le
paragraphe faisant remarquer adrien
duvillard seniors c'est à dire mon père
17 janvier 1960 devient le meilleur
schiro monde mois le 17 janvier 1997 je
me crachent là il fallait comprendre il
fallait comprendre que ce jour là mon
père du numéro un et moi ce jeu là je me
suis mis face à un mur physiquement vous
avez vu c'est face à un mur elle a fait
ça fait boule de ma tête et là j'ai
compris j'ai compris quoi j'ai compris
que les chemins de verre séparés j'ai
compris ce que ce jour là je n'étais pas
sur mon chemin n'était pas sur le bon
chemin
vidé ce souhait mon père même prénom
même nom même discipline
grosso modo j'étais dans ses pas
naturellement mon père m'a jamais eu de
pression un jour proche rien c'est juste
moi qui me suis mis cette pression
naturellement en fait
j'étais que dans les traces de mon père
j'étais pas sur mon chemin du tout et ce
chemin en fait ils menaient nulle part
il m'a mené jusqu'à l'âme il faut les
changer et je n'ai pas écouté les six
nuls de la vie et dans la vie m'a fait
un cadeau elle m'a mis à mu en face de
moi me dit tu vois tu peux pas aller
plus loin maintenant et je fais me
crasher compte ses murs il m'a fallu
juste et jusqu'à là pour comprendre
qu'il fallait que je fasse différemment
parce que jusqu'ici et sans aucune
entraide entre guillemets identité je
m'appelais adrien de villars comme on
pêche du ski comme mon père donc je
skiais sans identité il fallait créer ma
propre identité
donc ce jour là m'a fait comprendre
quelque chose de vraiment très important
qui pour moi maintenant et drive à ma
vie c'est que les objectifs sont là pour
vous donne une direction mais on passe
une vie sur un chemin donc le chemin est
plus important que l'objectif on aime
moi je me suis construit sur un chemin
sont si peu derrière sur l'allemand je
me suis construit qui je suis maintenant
on passe une vie sur un chemin en fait
que traverser l'objectif d'accord donc
ça pour moi c'est la chose la plus
importante qui a reculé vécu à travers
cet accident
alors on s'aperçoit que quand on vit ce
genre d'évènements que la ville n'est
pas là pour vous embêter d'accord la vie
n'est pas vous embêter la vie est là
pour vous faire progresser pour faire
évoluer et les échecs que l'on vit font
partie de la vie donc en fait les échecs
sont hostiles avons fait évoluer autant
faut-il les voir cela et moi quand j'ai
vécu cet échec là m'a fallu un peu de
temps il m'a fallu beaucoup
d'introspection pour les chercher la
véritable raison de ce qui s'était passé
et quand j'ai trouvé le véritable raison
ça m'a complètement libéré et je suis
devenu ce que je suis maintenant ça
c'est vraiment le message le plus
important
alors si genre si je résume en fait et
avec trois lectures et dans la première
lecture qui était de dire en fait je me
suis trompé l'objectif c'était de la
raison mais la deuxième mouture mes amis
alliés mais non c'était l'objectif forme
point départ si tu enlèves tous les
problèmes de dégoût et le problème de
performance mais la troisième lecture
qui est pour moi le plus importante
c'est cela c'est que le chemin est plus
important que l'objectif est comme gelée
dit on sait que traverser les motifs et
on vit sur un chemin alors pour résumer
ça en fait avant j'avais une phrase qui
était celle là qui était à vaincre sans
péril on triomphe sans gloire avant
quand je courais en coupe du monde
j'avais mon petit drapeau et mme simon
drapeau je vais me planter là bas il ya
rien qui m'a arrêté j'avais voté moudre
à pau où j'avais envie de le planter je
prenais une baffe au passage c'est pas
grave je portais mon drapeau où j'avais
envie après mon accident
la vie m'a fait un peu prendre de la
hauteur un peu de maturité et maintenant
je passe sur un autre message qui est de
dire à vaincre sans apprendre on
triomphe sans comprendre
je n'ai de cesse maintenant d'apprendre
de ce que la vie me met en face de moi
pourquoi mes chaussons là en quoi la vie
et l'amour me faire évoluer les échecs
sont là pour vous faire évoluer autant
les voir en ce sens là plutôt que de
dire j'ai pris de chance non on remet à
6 échecs ou de cela on peut aller
chercher les cantines soit là qu'est ce
qu'on en fait merci
[Applaudissements]